all right let me
all right two seconds everyone i'm just
gonna
get things sorted my end
i can't hear anything
now i can't so this is a new platform
that i'm using to do this and
i'm now can't see myself so bear with me
two seconds everyone sorry about this
okay
quiet
i'm so sorry if i'm right i don't even
know what happened there
i can't see why it wasn't me can you
right we i can see everyone now we're
all good
claire what can you say i can't see
yourself i can see a blue circle with a
c
and every time i talk i can't see myself
and i can't hear claire and i can't
exactly so that everyone can see all
four of us so what i just did
is refresh and then come back in so
that's what i did but that's why i was
worried but
right let's let's go for that and we'll
come back but i'm going to stop so
everyone
um thank you for joining us sorry for
the
the technical issues um but if you could
let us know uh where you're joining us
from are you in the office
are you at home let's start there you
can use the the chat functionality
um and we can get going with that but
claire can you see yourself now
i can see myself sally you're good i'm
good
joe can you see yourself
no not yet hang on okay so if you if you
refresh
we'll be all good if you refresh refresh
the page that's what i did
and we're back in action right i'm gonna
i'm gonna tee this up
uh everyone watch the page just refresh
yeah it's refresh just normal refresh on
the browser
on the browser oh yeah
right i'm gonna i'm gonna tee this up
for everyone um
as i said thank you for joining everyone
so what we're gonna be doing
in this in this time together is the
first
20 30 minutes we're gonna have a
discussion
amongst us um with um the panelists
around how we can better overcome
imposter syndrome
then for the sort of next 20 30 minutes
we're going to then
do a lot of q a so before that
as well just to let all of you know
understand how we can use this platform
so as some of you are using the
the chat functionality and that's where
you can ask your questions
so when your questions come from in the
chat box i can then mark them as a
question
and then we can obviously answer them
when we get onto them so i'll be keeping
an eye on that what i'll also be sharing
with you all is some polls as well
throughout this session
just so it can help sort of um all of us
really understand how other people
feeling
and also just drive the conversation so
joe helped me with this and i think it's
important to say obviously we're talking
about something that
maybe some of us individually have
really struggled with we're
likely going to share some of the things
that we've percy struggled with as well
so when i spoke to joe around preparing
for this she said
it's really important everyone knows
that this is a safe place
and so if we are sharing our own stories
and stuff like that
let's sort of respect that if we're
showing some vulnerability
and the way that joe put it not sure how
great this is but
what what let's treat as what happens in
vegas stays in vegas so what happens in
this
webinar room stays in in this room right
so
before i get uh you want to introduce
yourself
and we start going into these questions
i just wanted to uh just
frame up imposter syndrome where did
this come from where was this born out
of
and just give some context for everyone
so i'm just going to read um a couple of
things and share something as well that
would be
valuable for all of you so the idea of
imposter syndrome
and what that basically means is that
the idea that you've only succeeded due
to luck
and not because of your merit so this
was sort of first identified in
1978 by psychologists pauline rose
and clance and suzanne iams and and they
published a paper around this so
initially it was actually focused on
women and how this uniquely affected
them
obviously this was in the 1978 but and
then what they then
later on did and found out was how
imposter syndrome
affects uh men and women and and we both
experienced this and they then
later updated their their papers and and
where this was sort of born from
now something that they've actually
produced is
an actual imposter test that all of you
can actually take which i'll share in a
second which could be really useful for
all of you
to check out um but basically today
imposter syndrome can apply to anyone um
and it's anyone who maybe isn't
sort of able to internalize their own
successes
and and that's what this is about and
what we're going to be discussing today
so as i share that imposter test i'm
going to come to you joe first for you
to introduce yourself
those that may not know who you are and
then sally i'll come to you after and
then we'll
we'll get into this finally
thank you thank you so thank you all for
having me today my name is joe phillips
i'm the founder of a coaching
organization that's called fresh futures
and fresh futures was born because
i have a real passion to work with women
and actually women in society face
some real challenges when it comes to
imposter syndrome or when it comes to
self-promotion
and that has a fairly deep effect in
terms of their careers
so i work as a real women's champion so
i'm an executive coach and mentor for
women and i work for women
with women to help women overcome their
barriers within work so whether that be
to achieve a promotion to help them
close that gender pay gap
to achieve a leadership role or to move
from leadership to vice president so i
work with women to help them radiate
confidence
within their career and beyond and it's
an absolute pleasure for me to be here
and thank you so much
for inviting me i'm really i'm really
looking forward to this morning session
amazing thank you so much and sally hi
there
yeah thanks so much for having me so um
i've got a kind of
a slightly different background so i've
worked in recruitment for 20 years
i'm still working in that capacity now
so still very much billing
and managing two teams and but i've
recently set up
a coaching business myself so a career
coaching business again focusing on
supporting women
i'm sure that we'll go into a lot of
this and throughout the discussion but
um i've worked in a heavily male
dominated environment
for most of my professional career um
and so yeah working with women is
something that i'm really really
passionate about in terms of their kind
of career development
and last but not least claire hi
um firstly this isn't my house this is
the office
this is my front room um so so my name
is claire so i
am my background is pulling recruitment
i have
just over 12 years experience in
recruitment now i spent 11 years with my
previous company
um during that time we grew from 20 to
around
800 people i think when i finally left
um lived all over london san francisco
new york berlin
and and then left last year took a bunch
of time out and
launched storm three and we're a health
tech recruitment firm at the beginning
beginning of this year we're already 30
people
um we are focused on yeah
start-ups and scale-ups and health tech
and it's yeah mad mad crazy time to time
we've had a couple of conversations
about it but um
but yeah really excited to to be on i
think
uh diversity is something that is so
close to my heart
um obviously working recruitment i've
worked in very male dominated
environments and
and actually where i am now it's it's
far more female heavy um my team is
extremely diverse
and yeah it is amazing to see how
different things can be when you're an
environment like
what we've created here so yeah looking
forward to today awesome
right so let's get into this so where
where i want to start
is clear i'm going to come to you first
so this
this phrase imposter syndrome what
what what does it mean to you when
you're
i think you already know my opinions on
it and um
how do i phrase this
i actually fundamentally disagree with
the phrase
syndrome i it
that all the themes around it i think
are so important to talk about
um but the actual before i talk about
what it means to me i i do have to say
that i do find the actual phrase
i wish we could re rename it or give it
something else because just the phrase
itself
i feel personally i mean the word
imposter
and then the word syndrome like it's
just for me
so i'd love i mean i don't think we've
got the power on
just this hour for us to re-change the
whole phrase
to the world but firstly i do want to
get that across because i think it's i
don't know i find it really frustrating
that it's called that but
um what does it mean to me i mean i
think i definitely have been through
ups and downs in the last 12 years of
when i felt it when i haven't and
and and the point i would make is that i
didn't actually know what it was
for a very long time until someone that
i used to work with said
oh you're suffering from imposter
syndrome and i said what's that and then
i googled it
and i have to say then knowing what it
was and googling it
i'd probably then suffer from it more
than i would have done had i not even
know
what it was if that makes any sense yeah
it's interesting um
so yeah lots of experiences i'm sure i
can share on the kind of the ups and
downs
and rides of of how i felt it and
experienced it but yeah in a nutshell
that's kind of
my initial stance on imposter syndrome
if that answers
yeah no absolutely and sally what about
you what what does this phrase mean to
you
you're really interested i agree um how
harshly with what claire said in terms
of
it being called what it is um and i
think it's you know we could liken it
also to be
a victim if you like of domestic abuse
or of
or abuse you know you're not a victim
you're a survivor
and it has a very submissive um and very
negative i think
connotation to say you are an imposter
or you are suffering from some kind of
syndrome the word suffer even who
doesn't kind of sit right with me
i've got common wrangles of how i look
at it
the first one is that um
they are just feelings so whatever it is
you're feeling or you're experiencing i
think it's really important that we
acknowledge those but they are just
feelings
another way i really look at it is i
think because of the work i do with a
lot of women who are experiencing these
feelings
i actually see impostor or imposter
syndrome as an opportunity for growth
so once we really identify what those
feelings are and whether we can unpack
those
it's really an opportunity to not sit
behind a label and say i'm suffering
from this but this is an opportunity for
us to grow and develop
so um that's my take on it i love that
yeah just complete change of language
powerful and then last but not least
anything to add i guess
uh joe to that what the clarendon
so i think i think to claire's point as
far as um it being called a syndrome
you know we're in 2021 and i think
syndromes are not really not where we
want to be we want to be distancing
ourselves from that as much as possible
phenomenon as in it's something that we
can't quite
can't quite pin our we can't quite pin
it down to exactly what it is
that stops us from feeling as much as
perhaps
we could i think to claire's point is
probably a slightly
different way it's a reframe of looking
at it it's it's a phenomenon
and it's a general feeling of whereby
and we've all been there haven't we
we've all been there where we sat on a
one-to-one or a checkpoint and a leader
or a manager has said to us oh you did
really well there
and in our minds we don't go yeah i did
do really well and thank you for that
weekend
doing my job and i was really lucky and
actually the wind was blown in the right
direction and i just had a few good
deals
and before we know it our ability to
self-promote
and our ability to take that praise
has kind of disappeared out the window
and and this this phenomenon this whole
i'm not good enough feeling has
has arrived and has sat with us and it's
this need to be humble it's this need to
be
quiet this need to not take that that
initiative and say well thank you for
that and yes i did do a good job
so that's you know one of the things i
think around imposter phenomenon
is that it is just a feeling and it's a
voice inside our head
it's a narrative that we have that tells
us that we're just not good enough to be
in this situation or we're just not good
enough to be managing
this particular piece of work as it were
so
and i think again from a broader
perspective
we know it affects men and women what we
also know
is that when we take ftse 100
organizations for example
only 50 have female chief execs
if we took the foot c 250 that trails
behind
at just two percent having female execs
and then to add insult to injury we've
got a gender pay gap that's damning
whereby women are still paid two-thirds
less than men within the recruitment
sector
so whilst imposter phenomenon affects
both
genders it's fair to say
that women still struggle with the whole
feeling of
not being good enough so that would
definitely be my group
on it sure okay so let me clara just
muted yourself quickly just because i
can hear the background noise but on me
it's fine you don't have to worry about
anything so i'm just going to share a
really quick poll with everyone on let's
just let's just first start like
has everyone here experience these
feelings that everyone's sort of just
talking about on how we
think about them i'm going to share that
in a second but joe what i want to come
back to you with and where i want to
sort of take this first
so back to what um you've all been
saying it's feelings it's a voice in our
head
so joe when when can we i guess expect
to experience
feelings and this internal dialogue more
often when can it become more louder
when can it
feel more stronger in our career do you
think when can we sort of expect to
have these feelings arise more out of
interest when do you think we can expect
these
so i really pondered over this you know
in terms of when can we expect the
feelings and what i tried to do
was figure out from my own lived
experience and from my clients lived
experiences
when you know what's the timeline
what's the what's the general timeline
when when might we feel
these feelings and actually i think that
these feelings take
root really from a very early age and
what we know about imposter syndrome is
that they're generally born from
from drivers and what we mean by drivers
is they're generally born from
communication that's come in
to our zone and the narrative that we've
had around us as we've grown up
so it might well be that for those
people who who experience imposter
phenomenon
that what happens is is that they can
hear the voices of
that's not good enough do that again
because that's not perfect do redo your
homework that's not perfect
redo that exam result that isn't perfect
why would you say that to me that wasn't
the right answer
you know and again particularly females
younger females
would have all heard it we've all heard
parents say to their daughters be quiet
don't be so bossy stop taking over the
conversation
and you know or wait you turn don't
interrupt and i think that
so what happens is our drivers really
are instilled in us this narrative comes
from
a younger age and then as we move
through our career within recruitment
there's every chance that between what i
tend to see is that between about week
about month six and about month nine if
people are new to the industry
that's where we feel our first wobble
and that's usually because we've we've
seen what success looks like and we're
desperately trying to get
there and haven't necessarily been able
to create
a pipeline that is sustainable we've had
lots of bumps in the road
but then i think as we move through our
careers imposter phenomenon can hit us
at any transition point so whether it's
transition from one desk to another desk
one industry to another industry in
recruitment whether it's from
management into leadership whether it's
because a recent deal has flopped
and we then bring all of those
experiences into the new deal
it's it's generally whenever there's
vulnerability around us whenever we we
have
um a situation that's new to us the
impositive phenomenon can really hit
and i think that the key is to recognize
it the key is to know
that it's just a phenomenon it's just a
thought it's just a feeling that we're
going through
it's really interesting and then sally
what about you then where obviously you
work with people their careers and
obviously worked in recruitment for a
really long time
where where did where have you seen this
show up and maybe your colleagues and
then also
people that you've worked with more
typically i absolutely think the
triggers
are any type of change anything that's
going to push your comfort zone any new
situation
any yeah changing career absolutely and
that's the work i do kind of you know
within my coaching practice
but at work i think within recruitment
you know we've all worked in recruiting
for a long enough time to know how
things evolve and how quickly things
evolve
we are constantly tested in terms of
you know um pitching for new clients
winning new
new business um you know adopting new
technologies you know the challenges
that we've had to
overcome and face over the last 12
months you know everyone going online
everyone adapting the way they're
recruiting these are things are
constantly pushing us and we're
constantly having to evolve as recruit
as recruiters um and so these feelings
can you know can come up all the time
and lots of different guises um
we've experienced a lot of change
haven't we
in fact when you ask a question where
have you experienced me and when i first
started recruitment there was like a
roller decks on my desk you know we
didn't even have
we didn't even have um email you know
yeah so yeah
yeah i'm not surprised yeah hang on yeah
no that's this pay for that
well just to um claire i hope that's
okay i'll just did you find that okay
just don't meet yourself and stuff cool
all right
so just it's okay just to share this
with you all
so um with the pole so the first poll
that we did was have you experienced
feelings of imposter syndrome before
68 of people said yes they have 21
of people said yes i experienced these
feelings quite often and then
uh 11 of people said maybe but i'm not
sure if it was imposter syndrome
so a lot of people there that clearly
sort of deal with these feelings or that
internal voice quite a lot right
so um i think i i think it's i'm really
not surprised by
when we're yeah i guess out of our
comfort zone has changed we're doing
things we haven't done before
it's the first time that we're doing
that so i guess claire obviously you've
um
really built yourself a recruitment
career for a long period of time now
obviously recently you launched your own
business
obviously i'm sure there's been a lot of
firsts for you or doing things for the
first time yeah
like i guess what where have you tip
when you've started to sort of feel
these feelings or that entire internal
dialogue has started to become a bit
louder than usual
where where do you then go do you go to
a particular moment you go well actually
no i've done all of this
and i look at my past to show no i can
do this or i don't know where
i want to go into like sort of maybe
practical tips here that people can use
when they
you start feeling these things it's
interesting
because i i did start thinking about it
and think about when did i first
experience it and
and i have to say um growing up
i never definitely never experienced it
and i i saw i went to an all-girls
school
and um i don't know if there's a theme
there
in that and i went to a school where we
were
you know it was it wasn't a private
schools and as an all-girls school in
kent
you know and it's a good school but we
were
constantly told that we could achieve
anything we wanted to achieve
and like that belief and and i do think
there is something there i don't know
it's
a whole different conversation but i i
do think there is
if i look at my group of friends that um
you know i'm still best friends with
that i went to to school with i do think
there is something there
in that that enabled us to to not have
to experience any of that
for a long time but then i guess you
know
then coming into recruitment and
entering a very male dominated industry
you know as kind of being discussed
already it's like you know one day
you wake up and it's like you've just
been like you just
it's just like all of a sudden it hits
you kind of
where am i going what am i what what am
i doing like
am i am i good enough um you know i've
spoken about this quite openly and that
you know i i my previous company was a
very male dominated company and
you know it did get to the point where
last year i you know i
i left i left the company to leave the
industry all together
um i took six seven months off in which
i thought you know what
i i want to be a founder i want to be a
ceo
i don't you know i want to be changing
those statistics
that that you've already spoken about
joe like that's what i want and even if
i fail at it i don't care i want to try
and i think i got to the point where i
just thought
how am i ever going to get there and
maybe it's just not possible in
recruitment
like it's been a great career but and it
took me
it took me a good six months six i took
a load of time out
and and i i had to really you know my
confidence completely dropped for a long
time in which i was like i don't want to
do recruitment anymore and i don't know
if i
i can do it and yeah for me it took a
lot of time out to
surround myself by people that
gave me my confidence back and and also
reminded me of
all the things i'd achieved and that
none of the things i'd achieved in my
career
were down to luck and you know i was
very fortunate that i had people around
me to
to convince me to get back into what i
love which is
which is one we're delighted to have you
back in the room
i think it's you know i do think
practical tips are like you've just got
to really recognize that
and i was really easy to say like it's
so normal i still get so nervous about
things i was
petrified before i before i started this
i remember i was i was in america
um and during my time out and you know i
was saying to my boyfriend i was like
i'm so scared i can't do this i can't do
this what are you on about you know but
that was normal that was
normal nerves i think it's about being
really honest and open with yourself
and the people closest to you to always
know the balance of
is it natural nerves and natural anxiety
of
stepping into something new or are you
or are you tipping on the scale of
really lacking confidence or really
needing some coaching or some help or
people to help to help you you know i
think it is about
trying to trying to recognize that and
knowing where you stand between the two
because
i i do also think for anyone that's a
high achiever or a slight perfectionist
or really cares about what they do
you're going to feel
all of these things it's normal i think
it's just about trying to
trying to recognize when you know that
it's it's the scale is going too far
on the yeah
does that make sense yeah no it does
honestly thank you so much for
sharing that and yeah you've had had
michael in there say what you're saying
is really relevant
happens every day and some obviously
environments can really
take away that person's confidence right
um and
there's more questions i want to ask but
i want to i want to jump straight to
this question from kim
and sally i'm going to come to you um
because i think this is something that
you probably spend a lot of time on and
it's how
how can we stop so we've ended up going
to confidence quite quickly right
um which makes sense but like how can we
how can we start building this back up
in your life how can we if we recognize
that
like claire said here i actually
realized i did my confidence was not and
these things like how can we then where
do we go to start building this back up
in your opinion
and i think it's a really poignant
question at the moment because um
somebody who i've introduced to the
event a guy called kev hope you're on
there kev say hi if you are you know we
have a very similar question we had a
very similar
conversation earlier on this week in
that he's been out of work for 12 months
now
and actually is having a huge impact on
his confidence and i think a lot of
people
who are in a separate similar situation
are so my tips when you're looking at
confidence
is to and this is a lot of the work that
i do with my clients
almost like kind of first session if you
like it's really reconnect with who you
are
at the moment especially there's lots of
lots of things that are unknown you
don't know what the future is going to
hold
you're pushing yourself out of the
comfort zone your brain doesn't like
that your brain likes to know exactly
what it's doing
any given moment in the time it likes
predictability which is why
we start to feel uncomfortable it's a
physiological reaction to when
we are trying to push ourselves out of
our comfort zone or into the unknown
reconnect with exactly who you are and
this is i'm sure what claire's done
over the last year or so is just
remember what a bloody badass you are
you know remember
i think it's really important we as
women as humans
we're so self-deprecating we are so easy
to push away all of our achievements to
one side to put them down to whatever we
want to and to put them down to luck to
put them
you know but we really struggle with
remembering all the challenges that
we've overcome
all the things that make us who we are
and our the
you know the individuals that we are so
all the values that we really really
strongly
believe in and why we're doing what
we're doing so claire's example is
perfect
she wants to change the industry she
wants to change her narrative and she
wants to make an impact
that and understanding that why and that
driver is the thing that's going to get
claire out of bed every single morning
whether she's lacking confidence or
feeling
absolutely amazing about herself and
this is exactly what happened with my
launch my coaching business and coming
from someone who
is a high achiever at work i've always
you know i love my job i love
recruitment i've always strived
to be the best and to build the most
money it's just who i am i'm like a
competitive
person through and through but then when
i went into my coaching business i was
just like oh
like well no one's going to spend any
money i've got not haven't got anything
to say
you know although i had this passion and
i've got a post it on my desktop that
says show up because the results you get
and
because of the impact that you make you
know
forget about the fear do not let fear
control you because i think it's so i'm
happy if you're there
so i think it's really important that
you're doing this and you remember why
you're doing and you would connect with
the reasons you're doing it because that
is going to be your driver and that is
going to be able to override
any feel any confidence issues that you
have yeah i love that and just
before i come to you really quickly i
guess on that i think the bet i feel
like personally when i've done stuff
like that because i've
i've really tried to make sure i
reconnect and i understand what that is
for me
like what are really good practical
questions that we can ask ourselves that
can sort of hopefully
try and uncover the these feelings and
understandings
out of interest what typical questions
you share
oh i thought we've lost you object oh it
was that to me i thought you sorry
no sorry sorry i'll take that back nice
okay i took that back to sally sally i
was going to say
it's okay it's okay it's okay sorry
so i love the way that you articulated
that and that's something that i
i feel like i make myself do like
regularly so i guess just to be really
practical for people here like
what questions are good questions to ask
themselves that could sort of try and
uncover that because sometimes
people don't even ask the questions
right we're talking about self-awareness
here and we're talking about
so sorry yeah sorry back in the game so
absolutely
and so there's a lot of different things
you it's all about reflection
okay and it's all about remembering all
the things so
you could ask yourself the questions
what have i been my key achievements
what is it that i enjoyed about what i
do what is it that's driving me to do
the thing that i want to do so what is
driving me for change
once you have got those because at the
moment and when people don't write these
things down
they go round and round and round around
in your head and it becomes annoying
and then you start talking yourself out
of stuff right if you put it down on
paper and you journal and you get those
thoughts out it's a really cathartic
experience
and you're able to answer yourselves the
question so when you then have a doubt
so when you write something down you
think oh i can't do that because
okay that's what we call a limiting
belief you need to flip that
180 and make it a liberating assumption
so rather than saying
this is a good one for me i can't um
you know i'm terrible i i know they're
public speaking so rather than saying
i'm terrible at public speaking
you would flip that question around to
say if i was good at public speaking
and then your approach to that public
speaking so that your approach
to that challenge and when you flip it
around
you are asking your subconscious mind of
a solutions focused approach
to whatever that challenge is as opposed
to it just being a full sentence which
is
i'm terrible at public speaking yeah
interviews okay if i was good at
interviews what skills and attributes
would i have to display
okay well i'd have to be a strong
communicator i'd have to know my subject
i'd have to do some research on the
company
so automatically your brain is going
into a very
you know less submissive but more
proactive approach to solving that
problem for
us and going back to the point that joe
made earlier about the way that we
talked to our children
and what was expected of us in our work
environment we are expected to be
solutions focused
we are expected to come up with answers
you know claire if you go to one of your
team now and say this is the problem
that we've got
say marketing they'll go i'll go and
sort this out for you
this is the approach that we need to
have in terms of our own self
development
so what open ended questions can we ask
ourselves to solve the problems that
we've got and the problems
are the imposter that's a very
long-winded way of saying
just be reflective no
thank you for sharing that so joe i
guess where i want to take this really
quickly on the confidence piece
um i just want to sort of acknowledge um
kevin's message here because he's been
really open and shared
um a great story here so sally do you
know kev do you
yes i do yeah briefly yeah we've had
some interaction yeah great guy
so let me just frame this up i guess
what what sort of spikes my interest
which is something that i
struggle with which i think actually
goes into confidence is sort of part of
what
uh kevin said here is around being
getting better at sort of taking
positive feedback
um that's definitely something that i i
struggle with i i don't know i just
personally i find it quite cringy and
hard to like talk about myself and like
when
someone actually praises me i don't know
i find it hard so
i guess obviously on that like how how
does that how does that link
to like confidence and with this joke
because i'm sure that's quite common
i feel like so if you've seen this with
people that you've
worked with like where yeah talk to us a
bit about that because i find that
interesting
so the first thing i would say is is
kevin you are not on your
own this is this is super neither you
machine this is you know this is wife
across our industry i've been in the
industry now for 25 years
and the thing about the recruitment
industry is that we're only as good as
our last deal
right we're only as good as the last
candidate we placed
we're only as good as the last client
conversation so what happens is that the
narrative that we all draw on
is the one where well i did do it but i
might not do it again
and that's because our industry our
industry really works on this whole
recessive feeling it works on a feeling
of
this might not happen next time rather
than there is no reason for this not to
happen next time
so i think i just want to refer before i
answer
um the question i want to refer back to
an exercise that
um sally was mentioning earlier which is
around limiting
beliefs and one of the things that
will help for everybody who's the other
end
is whether you've got maybe a post-it
note on your desk or whether you've got
a card
i can wholeheartedly admit i'm working
with these in front of me always do
whenever i'm doing anything like this
pop on the post-it note for me or in
front of you at the moment on your desks
put on your biggest limiting belief so
hashem you can do this clay you can join
him whatever
just pop on there for me what your
biggest limiting belief might be
so it could be it could be i'm not good
enough
it could be i'm not going to make this
next deal it could be the conversation
i'm about to have with my next client is
all going to go wrong
put it on there for me i like this
you like this i thought you'd like this
she likes to get stuck in there you've
even got your sleeves rolled up there
so what you're in you can put down
however many you feel however many you
feel right
now when you look at that limiting
belief and when you look at the wording
let's ask yourself the question
when you look at those words would you
in the first instance would you say
those words to somebody else
would they be words that you would use
with somebody else
or would you be much kinder with
somebody else and refrain
the second question that i would ask you
and again this is about reflection going
back to what sally was saying the second
question that i would ask you
is is that true
in every scenario so if it says i'm not
good enough
if it says i can't do this is that true
in every scenario so what is your
evidence
that that is true for the next time
yeah and if you can't find evidence and
and the sessions that i do with my
clients that take a lot longer than this
and of course we deep dive into every
limiting belief in where they've come
from but actually when you think about
it
if you can't give evidence that that's
definitely going to be the case next
time pick up your post it and turn it
over because it's just a belief
it's just a narrative that you're
telling yourself
[Music]
so that was what are you thinking hashem
you've obviously what well i
no i just i just reflection
i'm gonna fail that's my that's my
that's what really comes up for me
yeah and then i love that second
question because that that's the
sort of the gives you space then we'll
go hang on a minute well why am i saying
that to myself and it's
like you said in every scenario is that
true and it definitely isn't
so it's like hang on a minute why why am
i choosing to try and find things that
back up that i'm gonna foul piece rather
than the i don't know yeah i just
actually really got me thinking i think
that's a
great exercise so that's one of the oh
sorry sally go on
no i just think that yeah it's a really
good point yeah and i've still you go
and then i
i've got something to add that yeah
really really important
are you sure i don't know no please i'm
i'm
joe can't keep talking so that was
so that would be one of my first
responses in terms of why in the
recruitment industry
why do we look at ourselves with such
negativity and it is because
the whole industry comes from this
recessive vibration
i won't get that next deal i might not
be able to negotiate i won't quite get
what i want so actually it's it's
cultural within our industry and it's
deep seated and i think claire
you know as you mentioned earlier in
your intro you are kind of disrupting
this industry
with everything you're doing and no
doubt the narrative is different within
your within your particular organization
and then the second part to my answer
and in terms of um
why we're lacking confidence which i
think going back now that was the
question wasn't it
private yeah yeah well it was the taking
positive feedback
where i came okay so the positive
feedback bit is much more
deep rooted and it's societal and
actually
men and women dislike it
when another person self promotes we
feel threatened by self-promotion we
feel like there's competition
when there's self-promotion and actually
society
society really struggles to listen to
other people self-promote and therefore
when we're being given feedback we're
being given praise
you know you did really well what
happens is we internalize it as
i could have done better there actually
i don't
and because we know again in recruitment
one of the other things that we do is we
pick up on
everything that we didn't do properly
through the a to z of that deal right
because we all know what the a to z is
of the deal we all know how to move this
candidate into their placement
we know that or into their contract or
into their temp position
equally as recruiters are also brilliant
at cutting corners
some of us can cut the sheet of paper up
so although it starts as a piece of a4
and we should have been doing everything
actually we can cut it into lots of
round circles whatever we do with it
and i guess the point is is that we know
what we've missed
and when we then get that feedback we
think
they don't know that i didn't do this
bit or i missed that bit out and so
we're much more likely to be
self-deprecating than we are just say
yeah do you know what the result is i
got the result great thank you for that
so again it comes back to it's societal
it's personal as in it was our deal
and we know the bits that we could have
done better and it's also about the
industry
that the industry one thing i'd like to
add to that sorry if you don't please
just stop because i was thinking
just it's on your point of being
self-deprecating and
i remember probably about five years ago
a male colleague of mine he said to me
like like
you need you need to start talking more
about what you've achieved or what
you've done
or good things you've done because not
just because it's about you but
because there's a whole room of
women in this organization that want to
hear your story
and you just you don't tell it and it
made me
it flipped it on it it made me kind of
flip it on its head in a bit in
realizing
actually like i do
you know we do also then oh when you
when you feel like you're telling your
story
because you owe it to other people
because it's going to help them
that's what's really helped me because
then
it kind of takes it away from i'm being
braggy
because like because i am humble and i
do hate i hate
you know we can all come on here and
sound super confident but
it's you know that is you know it does
still feel uncomfortable to talk about
and
yeah that's impossible that's why we're
here but yeah i think
for me you're flipping the narrative of
actually i i went to other people i owe
it to
that 21 year old girl that's wanting to
have a career in recruitment to actually
tell her my story and
inspire her and if i can change one or
two to people's journeys
that that for me really helped in in
in allowing me to be more open about it
to making it not about me
um that was the kind of thing the thing
the thing that flipped it
most for me i just thought i'd add that
one because yeah and that was
the main thing that made it everything
change when i finally started kind of
being a bit more open about stuff yeah i
think that's such a good point claire
and i think
absolutely paying it forward you're
right you know we've got
you know it goes all the way back to
saffron jets you know when people
you know when women choose to you know
not vote
and you know i'd find it really
difficult to like you know bite my
tongue and be like you're
kidding me people have women have died
for the rope by
you know right for you to vote please
even if you don't know who you're voting
for you know it's your
you've got a right to do it and i think
those things it is really important to
pay things forward
and also equally it's important to use
for us to use our platforms to
showcase people who haven't got that
those opportunities i do like a show
every single week
about showcasing women on my linkedin
and i just think it's really important
and also it's really important i think
especially for my clients to realize
that
you're no different we're no different
to each other you know if i can do it
so can you if you can do it claire
absolutely that means somebody else can
do it you know joe
you know the experience that you know
that you've gained it is it's really
important to showcase
our achievements i really agree with
that and also i just wanted to go back
to the point that you were making
i was gonna come back to that yeah in
terms of this kind of failure
um and this fear of failure
and number one i would recommend anyone
listens to
um how to fail by elizabeth dale day
it's the most amazing podcast
i've got a book on fail i can't find it
i've got a book on failure
it it is just as impossible it is a
phenomenon it is something that we all
need to be talking about
and we need to give ourselves the
permission to fail
because we are going to fail and failure
is good and if we don't fail we're not
going to succeed
so it is part of the process so i think
changing that narrative in terms of i
don't want to fail
to i'm going to fail and that's okay i
think is really quite liberating
and also in terms of the kind of
perfectionist piece and i don't think
we're going to have time to go into it
today
um is there are five different types of
imposters i'm sure we've all done a
little bit of research on them but one
of them
is the perfectionist but if we number
one perfectionism
you know perfect doesn't exist it
absolutely doesn't exist you know
and there was a question i don't think
we're going to have time to either in
terms of you know what do we do about
the ceiling
the ceiling doesn't exist right it's in
your head
perfectionism you know being purple tank
doesn't exist but what
if you're striving for perfectionism it
creates burnout
and also it really really kills you know
creativity
because you're too focused on the task
as opposed to being
open to everything else that's around
you that is gonna
develop you better in different ways so
those are my
best advice i'll get to you no thank you
and that i've just
linked that podcast for people to check
out i listened to her on
the stephen barlow podcast and i thought
she was awesome actually so i'm
definitely gonna check that out
and i guess where i wanted to take this
is into what
sort of kim's put there in the chat and
um
sadly i'll come back to you just on this
really quickly because it's
it's the sort of next poll that i have
really which is just basically focused
on like
so we're talking about how we can manage
things ourselves
ask the right questions try and find
better evidence and
these types of things obviously we spend
a lot of our time in
in the work context in the work
environment right so
obviously we've all yeah when we work
with our colleagues and stuff like i
guess
the sort of question i want to come back
to something for us to discuss
is like how what can we how can we sort
of try and
cultivate a space of support if we are
i don't know if we are feeling really
overwhelmed with am i good enough
i'm going to fail these types of things
i don't know if like what have you done
in terms of sally to make sure that
people feel supported what can people do
to get more support um from their sort
of work colleagues or their work
environment because that's where we
spend a lot of our time and
likely also obviously we have our whole
lives and we'll
face it in all different parts of our
lives but i think we're talking in the
work context here
so i guess yeah how can how can people
get try and make a space or get more
support internally do you think
i think number one i think number one
talk about it i think
and going back to joe's kind of point
earlier you know we are
institutionalized as recruiters right we
are pitched against each other from day
one in our jobs right and you're right
we're only ever as good as our last
quarter
so we are taught that you know
number one this is what you're going to
do these are the processes you've got to
follow in order to be
successful right and if you don't do
this and then you do you you fail
in inverted commas that's because you
haven't done what we said we do
but as we all know recruitment has
evolved and you know we don't now make
125
call connected calls a week because
that's not the way that we communicate
as human beings you know we are
you know we get more better engaged when
we're whatsapping our candidates you
know or sending little video messages
as opposed to making these connect calls
i'm going off in a tangent
but i think sorry and i think number one
we've got to talk about it
okay and we've got to celebrate our
individuality
and we know that if you've got a target
of 250k
right the three top billers who who are
achieving that are all going to do it in
completely different ways
and that is the things that we've got to
celebrate so sharing stories i think is
really important
i also think it's important if you're
looking at it from a
um personal perspective that
as human beings we respond well
to positive human interaction okay
and so people don't like to push the
boundaries and debate and do
you know say things are controversial
because they like to be liked and they
want to and it's because we are safer in
numbers essentially
big groups we're safer numbers which is
why we try and please
and that's okay give yourself permission
to do that give yourself permission to
say
it's okay that i want to be liked by
other people and i want praise by other
people that's not a bad thing
but on the flip side of that by offering
up your opinion
and giving a different point of view and
going back to claire's point earlier
about having a very diverse workforce
the positive impact that can have is
that no one is going to agree with
everything you say but it's going to
spark debate
and if you spark debate that is going to
have a chain reaction
to a positive change it's going to maybe
make you think of a different way of
doing it so rather than kind of
suffering in silence and thinking oh god
i'm not good enough
saying this is how i'm feeling today
have you experienced something similar
how did you overcome it um and
yeah and then share those experiences
together to be able to move on i think
those things are really really important
yeah i love that claire i'm going to
come to you next and then we've i've
we've had a great question
come through which i really want to
discuss but obviously claire you've
recently just hired a whole load of
grads right so they're going to be doing
a lot of
things for the first time and things are
going to show up but just to add to this
the poll that we had on
have has had your company ever supported
you will communicate with you about
overcoming feelings of imposter syndrome
back to sally's point around talking
about it
70 of people said no we've never
discussed it internally right and that's
i feel like
where we can start changing this but
claire for you
how can we start talking about this more
internally what do you do with your
peers or colleagues that
could help people here do you know what
controversially
is something that i don't want to talk
about because i think if i can get the
culture right
from the outset and everyone realizing
believing that anything is possible and
i've got
an incredibly diverse team that was my
number one priority is to make sure
i apologize to any white man in
recruitment listening to this
i wanted to make sure i did not create a
company
full of white male recruiters right of
course i hired on merit
and but i have an extremely diverse team
which i'm so
so proud of and i genuinely think
yes i i do want to recognize that people
are going to sometimes
um you know lack of a bit of confidence
and anxiety
and all of that but actually i i'm a
firm believer that
if we can get the culture right where
everyone feels that they can achieve
and that they're not the odd one out and
that there are people
like themselves that are
doing great things then they it
shouldn't have to be
a conversation so yeah you're talking
about making sure that
there's the space to talk about how
they're feeling
and yeah like i think you know i think
it's so
i don't know going off in the tangent i
think
it's there's a lot to be said about
fixing the culture
and the places that we work in rather
than trying to fix the people i can
generally say i haven't felt
it once in the time that i've been here
because of the culture i'm in the people
i'm surrounded by
the diversity the support i really
haven't of course there's been days
where i'm like
god this is crazy busy and how am i
gonna
get all of this done but i've never felt
and that's because i'm in the culture
where it's
it's so supportive and there are so many
women around me
and and and you know our non-exec
director
vixx maloney is amazing you know i
i generally think there's a lot to be
said for that and i think my advice
not that as anyone has asked me for my
advice and this but if you're generally
at the point where you're
really struggling in with it
look at the culture and the environment
you're in and maybe you're just
in the wrong company yeah sure no i
respect yeah
i agree and also claire to add to that
if you can't find your tribe
in a place that you work you can find it
online do you mean you can find it
differently because i have i have sought
that externally
and it's given me what i've needed to
push on and
push on my career it hasn't always been
for the businesses i've worked with but
that hasn't
stopped my self-development if that
makes sense yeah
you're creating it where you are and i
just think yeah good for you
it's so inspiring listening to your
story yeah such a great point uh
such a it's such a great point
sally i think whenever i speak to
particularly on the narrative of women
in recruitment and having less role
models and stuff like that
a lot of people shared their advice well
actually you can the role models don't
have to exist within your four walls and
you can go outside of those
um but as we come to the end here i
really want to joe i'm going to come to
you on pharah's question which i'm just
going to put up on the scrimmage so i
think
is actually a real big part of this
actually which we haven't really touched
on which is actually
yeah so pharah said great exercise but
what if that voice what if that evidence
actually isn't your own and it's someone
else's right i think that's
such an interesting thing right if we're
actually sort of feeling the way that we
are because of them because what a
manager told us a year ago two years ago
six months ago or maybe even our parents
whatever right so other people's
opinions
i think that's such a interesting point
to raise it could be other people's
voices
that could be promoting why we're
feeling those
um those feelings that contribute to
imposter
syndrome and these things so what i
don't know where where where did you go
with that joe how do you feel about that
so i think in the first instance it's
important just to recognize that we're
all human
we've all had an upbringing we've all
had some fantastic experiences and
probably
some not quite so fantastic experiences
and they've all
they've all shaped us to arrive where we
are today and i think
farrah's pharah's question is just so
poignant because
she says well what if it's not what if
it isn't my voice what if i can hear
somebody else's voice
and actually often times when i'm
working with my clients
it is somebody else's voice and we
figure out who the voice belongs to
and from there and it's really important
that people recognize coaching isn't
it's not counseling it's not you know
we're not there to talk about what your
mum might have said to you when you were
seven but what we are trying to do is
we're trying to say okay
from their perspective what might have
been the reason that they did it
perhaps they didn't know that that was
the communication that was coming across
to you perhaps i didn't realize how it
landed and they certainly wouldn't have
realized how it's now with you still
today
but what can we do with that voice how
can we turn down the volume
of the voice and turning down the volume
of the voice is actually looking for
evidence that what the voice is saying
that what the words are saying is true
so have is it true that you are not good
enough
for this next client presentation
well where's the evidence well there
isn't any because i haven't done it yet
okay
so it's just a voice let's turn it down
you know what's the evidence
that my candidate won't take this next
job
and i really need this deal to go
through well okay let's look at what you
can control and what you can't control
and then what the evidence is
so i think yes it's important to
understand the history of that voice and
where it's come from but it's also not
to spend
so much time certainly with a coach
anyway it's not
you know like i said it's not
counselling but certainly looking at
well actually
where did that limiting belief come from
where does it come
from what does it really mean and
actually how beneficial is it for us
today sometimes they are beneficial
you know the whole look before you leap
is beneficial don't jump off a 60-foot
building that type of stuff you were
told as a child of course that's
beneficial
but actually is it beneficial to be told
you probably won't make it in
recruitment
you probably won't be good enough for a
promotion and to still be hearing those
voices
isn't beneficial so it's about
understanding the
approaches to turning that voice down
and turning the volume down
and you can do that easily by looking
for the evidence
guarantee that evidence isn't there yet
that evidence isn't there sorry
and what i usually do is ask my clients
to reframe so we reframe the narrative
and we pivot it 180 and we say okay
so what's the evidence that you're not
good enough for that presentation
there isn't any so you haven't failed
yet
and it's just about the reframe i think
that would be my answer
i love that so as we as we come to the
end here i'm just going to do a sort of
final poll to
just ask you all what you'd really love
us to focus on in our next event but
let's just go around to wrap this up
claire i'll come to you first
on sort of if if i am someone that maybe
is lacking a bit of inner confidence or
is is sort of stepping into um an
environment where i am unsure and
some of these feelings may come up that
we spoke about today
what what's what's our sort of best tips
or best bit of advice to sort of work
through that or make sure that
those feelings don't overcome us and
that in a dialogue gets too loud what's
your sort of best piece of advice
we'll go around
i think oh that's such a loaded question
but i think i
i don't know i think it's just look at
ways to spin
every failure and every mistake you make
as
and spin the narrative to a positive
i've made so many mistakes in my career
and
you know mess things up but and just
i know it's so much so easy so easy to
say but
you know don't expect to fail but
look at failure as a lesson and and look
at the positive you can take from it and
i said i know that's a very you know
that's not going to help people out
there who fundamentally lack
really that confidence but that's
probably one thing i would say
is you know just look at ways that you
can learn and
and try and find that positive that you
can take from that i appreciate that
thank you
sally what would be your sort of part
and piece of advice on this
it would be a little bit more
self-reflection and just being mindful
and it's the whole
other topic in itself of where you're
seeking that validation from it's okay
to seek validation but make sure that
the people you're seeking validation
from are the ones that are going to push
you and
allow you to grow and working on you
validating yourself and being true to
who you are and just remembering who you
are
is going to give you a huge amount of
confidence that's going to have more of
an impact on your confidence than
seeking
validation externally all about internal
work and tonal validation i love that
thank you
last but not least yes i think this is
about um
you know it's about it's about being
comfortable enough to voice
vulnerability
so this has happened today and i haven't
managed to achieve what would you do
being in a safe space whereby as a
culture you can do so
and then i think the other the other
really important point is to
is to really look at yourself and and
maybe maybe create for yourself a little
avatar
so i have an avatar so when my imposter
syndrome has arrived i have an avatar
and she's actually a 1980s very cheap
madonna and she arrives and she's got
like the little lacy gloves on
you know with no fingers and she blows
pink bubble gum in my ear and she says
you can't do it
i think so i have to physically mentally
sit her down
give her a cup of coffee and tell her
she hasn't got any evidence of that
and so again i think it's it's somehow
finding a way to lighten it
yeah accept it lighten it find a way to
kind of move on and focus on the
positive
yeah i love that well look joe claire
and sally thank you so much for
joining me thanks for being so open
honest a few technical difficulties
just part of uh doing these types of
things at the beginning but thank you
everyone for
for joining us really hope you've
enjoyed it i think we've
ended up having some some really great
conversation on a really important topic
that
isn't getting discussed a whole lot in
in people's work environments so
yeah i just want to say a huge thank you
to all of you that's joining me today
and everyone that's joined us so thank
you
thank you so much thank you thank you